good evening everyone my name is Valerie
McGinty and I'm the founder and
president of funder how many of you out
there know already that the California
state legislature is comprised of just
22% women Farra number of hands I really
can't see but and how many of you know
that thank you so responsive how many of
you know that that numbers been going in
the wrong direction that we're down from
where we were a decade ago we were 30%
okay fewer hands well I didn't used to
know any of these things certainly
growing up I was never political and I
wasn't really much of a feminist but one
thing I was was I was a doer my parents
taught me early on the importance of
hard work and instilled in me the sense
that I was capable that I could do
things well you could do that you could
do that and not just that I could do
things but that my life was up to me so
that if I wanted if I saw things I
wanted to have happen it was up to me to
make those things happen so when I was 8
year old
8 years old I started my own dog walking
business when I was 12 I started working
at the grocery store and when I was 16 I
was working at the bank and I loved the
sense of independence I got from work
both emotionally and financially I had
the feeling that I could handle any
situation that came my way I could work
with different kinds of people and I've
been stocking away the money since I was
8 years old so by the time I was 16 I
could buy my first car with my very own
money and that was a fantastic feeling I
also came from a family with a very
strong tradition of female leadership so
in my family women lead alongside men
and that's just normal but when I
emerged from my family cocoon and
entered the real world I saw that in
fact
that was not normal at all or at least
it wasn't how the rest of the world
operated and we know that women although
we're 50% of the population we are 70%
of the world's poor we know that women
make 70 cents to a man's dollar and if
you're a woman of color it's as low as
54 cents we also know that women are
vastly underrepresented in positions of
leadership so I mentioned or 22 percent
of the California State Legislature when
you look at the nation's governor's or
10 percent and we're four point six
percent of the CEOs of Fortune 500
companies now these numbers are
unfortunate not just for women but for
all of us because when women are seated
at those decision-making tables we make
a real contribution we know that
companies where women are at least 40
percent of the board of directors
outperform companies where there are
fewer women we know that women members
of Congress bring home on average nine
percent more than their male
counterparts and we also know that women
change the legislative conversation so
they bring up issues that would
otherwise be underserved or completely
ignored they tend to legislate more than
their male counterparts on issues of
health care education and poverty issues
that are critical to our nation's
success and so for a while I had been a
budding feminist but I still wasn't
necessarily political until 2015 when I
saw one of the early campaign speeches
of Hillary Clinton and I hadn't really
heard from her at least on the political
stage since 2008 when she lost in the
primaries to Barack Obama and in that
speech she told us the story she took us
from the day that she lost the 2008
primaries all the way to the day when
she accepted the nomination to be
Secretary of State
and she told that story with such
openness and wisdom and such a sense of
humor I was captivated and as I sat
there I let myself think about how that
would feel to have the first woman
president of the United States for me as
a woman for me as a citizen and as a
mother of two young daughters what would
that feel like I decided it would feel
pretty great
and so I was all in for Hillary and the
last time we saw her my husband and I
took our two daughters to one of her
final campaign appearances at the Billy
Graham Auditorium in October and when we
left that event the sense that we were
on the edge of something big was
palpable and then Trump won and I knew I
had to do something it wasn't just that
a misogynist with no political
experience had won the nation's highest
public office whether that wasn't just
that but it was also that he had beaten
a woman who was possibly the most
qualified person to ever run for that
office and he had done it with the help
of the votes of 62 percent of white
women and I thought to myself have we
accepted our status as second-class
citizens well I haven't because we're
not and so I knew I had to do something
but what could I do
and so I say slowly emerge from my fetal
position in the days and weeks following
the election one day I remember very
clearly sitting at my kitchen table with
my dad who was forever my booster
forever my collaborator and we were
talking about what could possibly be
done and as we brainstormed the options
seemed to dwindle to almost nothing
and I looked at him and I said I can't
turn away from this
I can't just hand this world off to my
two daughters and say well did my best
because I haven't not yet and he looked
at me with that perfect dad look and it
kind of it how are we gonna do this one
and then his eyes lit up and he said
well how about all the success you've
had with California fund raising what if
you could do something with that maybe
you could get not just one woman but 20
women elected and just like that it
clicked and I knew that's what I wanted
to do so now I had an idea but what I
really do something I mean after all it
has to already exist this is California
it's a big State someone must have
thought of this so I went around looking
for the wonderful organization that
already existed that I could just write
a check to it's gonna be very easy and
as I went up and down the state talking
about this idea
I talked to women who had run and won I
talked to women who had run and lost
I talked to women who had been in
California politics for decades and I
said do we really need this I mean
doesn't it already exist uniformly they
all said oh no it doesn't exist we and
we test Ennead it if you can do it you
should definitely do it and I thought to
myself troublesome isn't it it's so
great to just have a whiz-bang idea and
then you have to actually act on it it's
really the action part is troublesome
homework more homework so I thought to
myself and then there's that voice
inside of me that said who do you think
you are who are you I had the vague
feeling I was gonna be arrested you know
like oh you're starting your own pack
for women and
but then there was the answer to that
voice that said Who am I not to do it
and if I don't do it who's gonna do so I
knew it had to be done so I thought I
mean I'd rather know what it feels like
to try and fail than to wonder years
later could have done something I don't
know I kind of I decided to go on
vacation
read a book so so I thought I'm gonna
I'm gonna give it a go and there we were
on the one-year anniversary of Donald
Trump's election and we were celebrating
the launch of funder and I'm thrilled to
report that in the short time since our
launch we've been able to help elect
already our first progressive woman
Canada to the California State
Legislature and there's lots more to
come but for us it's the idea that we
want to help California be the first
state to reach gender parity California
is first in so many things why shouldn't
we be first to reach tender parity
I'll drink to that and so there we were
driving home from the launch and my 10
year old said to me mom I'm so proud of
you you took an idea and turned it into
a reality and so can you and I want to
leave you with one of my favorite poems
that I've adapted it's called it could
not be done and it's by Edgar Albert
guest somebody said it couldn't be done
but she with a chuckle replied that
maybe it couldn't but she would be one
who wouldn't say so
till she tried so she buckled right in
with the trace of a grin on her face if
she worried she hid it and she started
to sing as she tackled the thing that
couldn't be done and she did it
thank
[Applause]